well it came with plenty of fanfare
president biden's plan to cancel
thousands of dollars in student loans
for borrowers is designed to help
overcome debt but as john langler tells
us it's already a target of scammers
the program was proposed less than a
month ago people who meet an income
threshold can get up to ten thousand
dollars in federal student loan debt
wiped out problem is crooks are trying
to wipe you out of much more and you
think you're gonna get loan paid off but
you're gonna get unfortunately more debt
barry moore is with the better business
bureau he says imposters claiming to
represent the new federal debt
cancellation program are reaching out by
phone and by mail they ask you to fill
out a form to see if you qualify problem
is they get your personal information
and bank account details moore says some
scammers are getting victims to even pay
upfront fees no government agency is
going to ask you for a fee like that to
just see if you qualify for a program so
beware so if you're skeptical don't act
government agencies usually don't reach
out without a request when in doubt
contact the department of education
directly this can grow very fast by the
christmas holidays it could be exploding
if we're not cautious if you don't get
the word out john langler 8 news now